my name is shaquille
carbon i am a black man
in america i am a son of baltimore
a grandson of the carolinas and a
great-grandson
of sierra leone in west africa i grew up
in baltimore
and i'm here to talk about what this
means to black america
something that is important to me in my
core
in 2016 trump asks black america
what do we have to lose well i'll tell
you trump but we've lost in the last
four years
we've lost hundreds of thousands of
people who have died from covet 19
due to your inaction and your childish
actions
we have lost thousands taken by police
violence
we have lost to small businesses that
our families have worked so hard to
build
we have lost so much in four years and
we
are done losing my people are strong
my people are resilient there is a lot
that our community still have to gain
like living in a world where men do not
create legislation about women's bodies
and black people do not need legislation
to protect
our bodies and all of that is at stake
in this supreme court confirmation
56 years ago black people got the right
to vote with the voting rights act
we had to fight for that right on the
streets and in the courts
it didn't come easy and we will not let
it be taken away
the gop understands that the democratic
electoral power
is undergirded by the voting power of
black communities
they are trying to rush this
confirmation to challenge our sacrosanct
right to vote
the republicans are trying to change the
rules of our democracy
like the changes the rules of the
judiciary committee this morning
they're trying to change the rules
because they want not only to diminish
the power of our votes before election
day
but also take away our health care and
other rights
they're trying to change the rules of
the game as we all participate
this is not fair it is not right and we
will not
let them do it my community has fought
too hard for generations
to have the right to vote because it is
only with that right
that we can get health care that we can
get a decent education
and that we can have decent jobs housing
and more
amy coney barracks confirmation will
result in people in black communities
losing their health care
in the middle of a global pandemic
even as systemic oppression makes it
more likely for black men
to be afflicted by illnesses like
colorectal cancer
and more more people in my community
will die
because of this confirmation so no
i will not sit still while they change
the rules
and i ask all the democratic and
republican
senators to protect our communities
to protect our democracy and to reject
this illegitimate supreme court justice
confirmation
thank you
hi everyone i'm jamie manson from
catholics for choice
yes we exist catholics believe in
abortion rights it is true
we exist now many people have very
prudently avoided amy coney barrett's
extreme religious views
but as a catholic in good conscience i
feel i must
name it i must name it she
is a fulfillment of the law a very long
dream
of the bishops in the united states to
overturn roe
to deny people contraceptive
contraception
and ultimately just to control women's
fertility
now the trouble with that is the
majority of catholics in this country do
not agree with the bishops
and they do not agree with amy coney
barrett 68
of catholics want do not want to see roe
overturned
56 percent do not believe in abortion
rights
99 have used contraception of catholics
in this country
this this organization that she has
belongs to is an extreme
fringe group of catholics it's called
people of praise
and it is deeply problematic because it
is as extreme an interpretation of
catholic teaching as you can find
and it is not again consistent with the
vast majority of catholics in this
country
and how we feel one of the signature
things that amy coney barrett will try
to do
is to try to protect religious freedom
this very perverse
interpretation of religious freedom but
what does that mean
it means that they want the right to
impose their religious beliefs on
everyone
that's what religious freedom means to
these folks
this is these these groups like the
people of praise
are just a cover what they really want
is to impose those extreme religious
beliefs
this is a very serious situation because
if amy coney barrett gets
confirmed she will be one of six
catholic justices on the supreme court
five of those are extremely conservative
catholics it is disproportionate
and it is again not consistent with the
belief of the majority of catholics
even larger issues like climate change
the catholic church
believes in climate change we've written
the pope has written an entire document
about it
she does would not say whether or not it
existed
she's opposed the affordable care act
there is it's threatening to to destroy
it
that's a signature notion the rights of
health care for all people
is a fundamental belief of the catholic
social justice teaching
um she used the term sexual preference
even the catholic church even the
catholic church doesn't use it and we
have a pope that yesterday supported
civil unions suggesting that there's an
interesting separation of church and
state that the pope has in mind even if
extreme catholics in this country do not
our faith
calls us to follow our conscience and
matters of moral decision-making
and to respect the religious freedom of
all and that includes
allowing people to be free from
religious belief
annie coney barrett her rulings reveal a
pattern of siding with powerful people
and institutions
those are not catholic social justice
values at all
so we urge the senate to protect the
fundamental freedoms religious liberty
and right to reproductive health care
of all americans by rejecting the
nomination of amy coney barrett to the
supreme court
thank you
[Music]
hi i'm chris kang from demand justice
thank you just want to take a second to
take a step back
and remind everybody this is not normal
and this is not legitimate barely one
month ago we gathered at the steps of
the supreme court to mourn an icon
to mourn justice ruth bader ginsburg for
what she did as a lawyer for what she
did as a justice
to advance equality for all americans
and here we are in the fastest
confirmation process we've seen in
decades
seeing republicans stealing another
supreme court seat
to ram through their agenda that they
can't get done through congress
why do republicans want to rush this
through and have a vote
in record time because they want to
strike down the affordable care act
donald trump
just said in an interview that's coming
out on sunday
he wants the supreme court to end the
affordable care act we know why he
picked amy coney barrett
we know what she sent to do and we know
what she's going to do
but it's not just the affordable care
act it's overturning roe versus wade
it's stopping congress from passing
common sense gun violence prevention
laws
or addressing climate change or
addressing racial justice it's every
single thing that the american people
stand for
by vast majorities this
ultra-conservative
republican right-wing agenda is going to
be advanced through that building
instead of in the halls of congress or
through the white house
our democracy is at a tipping point
when a majority of the supreme court
stands to be appointed by a president
who lost the popular election
when two bill clinton did not lose the
popular vote
when two supreme court seats have been
stolen in the last four years
when they have broken the rules time and
time again
this is not a supreme court anymore this
is an asterisk court
this is the court that is undermined
democracy time after time after time
from bush versus gore to citizens united
to shelby county versus holder
to allowing partisan gerrymandering
allowing voter roll purchase making it
harder to unionize
this court stands against democracy what
have we seen them do during this
pandemic
time and time again they've voted
against making it easier to vote
whether it's in wisconsin or texas
or alabama last night where they won't
even allow
jurisdictions to choose to let you vote
curbside in a pandemic
a ruling we know is going to have a
disproportionate impact on people of
color and people with disabilities
that's what this supreme court is trying
to do they're undermining our democracy
they're making it harder to vote so that
they can get more republicans elected
who can put in more republican justices
and squeeze out as much power as they
can
and implement their ultra right-wing
agenda
what are we gonna do about it first
to be reformed and we need to add seats
to expand the court and restore balance
and legitimacy
so that this right trump super majority
does not have control over every aspect
of our lives
for the next 30 or 40 years thank you
thank you thank you so much chris for
that message
and absolutely absolutely agree i want
to thank everyone for coming out all of
those who are watching
virtually for uh just showing up right
the courts belong to us
and i also want to close with this 77
of people believe in the right to choose
they support roe v wade
that's a lot of people right and amy
coney barrett has just been an active
and vocal threat to
abortion rights in this country she's
been openly critical of the aca
and it is up to us the people to let
senate republicans know to let
all congress know that we will not stand
for this because these are our rights
these
these are our lives so we will be here
every day right every single day until
that nomination
and every single day through november so
every day every day
every day every day
every day every day
thank you so much
you